a masterful effort in storytelling and
absolutely one of the best space dramas
around director ron howard's apollo 13
rocked the world when it premiered in
1995 and has continued spellbinding
cinema lovers ever since the film tells
the true tale of the ill-fated apollo 13
lunar mission the apollo space program's
third attempt to land on the moon which
took place in april 1970 this
oscar-winning feature stars tom hanks
kevin bacon and bill paxton as a trio of
astronauts who experience a mid-mission
explosion that threatens their lives the
unexpected detonation dashed nasa's
dream of additional lunar exploration at
the time and it transformed the
expedition from one filled with hope
into a race to bring the men back to
earth in one piece there's a reason why
apollo 13 is regarded as ron howard's
best film yet and why it won all those
academy awards netflix subscribers have
until june 1st to discover the magic of
apollo 13. or else they'll be left
saying houston we have a problem
get into the spooky spirit a season
early with 2009's friday the 13th a
modern take on the horror movie classic
from the 80s supernatural star jared
padalecki leads the friday the 13th
refresh which centers around his
character clay as he comes through the
woods of the infamous camp crystal lake
to look for his missing sister he soon
discovers the remains of an abandoned
cabin and later learns that something
even eerier awaits him in the woodland
the machete wielding hockey mask wearing
serial killer jason voorhees while many
still prefer the original over this
revival this friday the 13th is as tense
as its predecessors it also had
significant commercial success and is
plenty satisfying in its own right some
long time franchise fans dug the film so
much that they've even placed it in the
upper tier of their personal best of the
series lists decide where you stand on
the original versus remake debate before
it disappears from netflix on june 1st
before will smith was a big blue genie
in disney's live-action aladdin he was a
bonafide leading man who played around
in all sorts of film genres one of his
most memorable performances came in
2007's i am legend in which smith stars
as a us army virologist who lives in
isolation after a virus wipes out most
of the world's population and which
turns the survivors into deadly
creatures known as dark seers aside from
all the soul smith poured into the film
i am legend also tickles the fancies of
just about every kind of movie fan it's
post-apocalyptic it's sci-fi it's horror
it's drama it's a gritty what-if story
and at times it's genuinely funny those
interested in catching it on netflix
have until june 1st before it's gone
forever
no
no no
blending together fictional found
footage and traditional cinematic
storytelling district 9 takes place in
an alternate johannesburg south africa
and addresses a number of heavy-hitting
themes in the process it tells the story
of the south african government
sequestering a group of malnourished
aliens in an internment camp featuring
charlton copley playing a bureaucrat
working for the mnu department of alien
affairs as his story progresses the film
explores what it means to be human and
how segregation and xenophobia affects
us all things go sour in the internment
camp after a long period of isolation
and what follows is a thrilling and
thought-provoking character drama
wrapped up in sci-fi goodness if this
sounds like your cup of tea load up
district 9 before it leaves netflix on
june 4th
this space fairing sequel follows the
titular guardians offbeat champions of
the marvel cinematic universe as they
face an attack from the sovereign race
and its leader iesha because it's the
guardians it quickly spirals into a
high-stakes adventure to escape
imprisonment and along the way they
discover the truth about star-lord's
father the ancient celestial ego played
by kurt russell no spoilers but he isn't
going to win any dead of the year awards
now that the world has entered the post
avengers endgame timeline we're all
waiting to see what marvel has up its
sleeve for phase 4. guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 is still on the distant
horizon so all fans have to savor the
franchise for now is the first guardian
sequel and if you haven't well you must
be so embarrassed
don't miss it before it flies off of
netflix on june 5th
francis ford coppola's vietnam war epic
apocalypse now is haunting visually
rousing and valiant one of cinema's most
enduring pieces of art martin sheen and
marlon brando lead the film as u.s army
special ops officer captain benjamin l
willard and the highly feared heavily
decorated renegade officer colonel
walter e kurtz whom willard is tasked
with taking out though apocalypse now
received mixed reviews upon its release
in 1979 it went on to receive eight
academy award nominations it was later
preserved in the library of congress's
national film registry and designated as
culturally historically or aesthetically
significant apocalypse now is
celebrating its 40th anniversary this
year and will depart from netflix on
june 15th so there truly is no better
time to revisit it or watch it for the
very first time check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you